[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin guten Abend zu einer
kompakten sonntagsendung mit Christian
Otto und mit sportlichen Highlights
Kanonen Fußball guten Abend wir schauen
auf die Themen von heute
unter Beschuss die Angriffe zwischen
Israel und dem Islamischen Jihad gehen
weiter eine Waffenruhe soll die Lage
beruhigen
wo steht die AFD Parteichefin Weidel
verurteilte im zdf-sommer-interview
Russlands Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine
und spektakuläre Wechsel in der
Bundesliga Anthony modest verstärkt
Dortmund Timo Werner kehrt wohl nach
Leipzig zurück
[Musik]
in diesen Minuten soll eine Waffenruhe
im wiederaufgeflammten Nahost-Konflikt
beginnen ob sie umgesetzt wird ist
unsicher laut Israels Armee wurde bei
Angriffen ein weiterer Chef des
Islamischen Jihad getötet militante
Palästinenser Antworten mit weiterem
Raketenbeschuss aus Gaza auch auf
Jerusalem wo es heute ebenfalls
Luftalarm gab die Angst vor einem Krieg
bleibt groß Andreas Kühnast
es gibt am Ende dieses Tages mehr
Hoffnung als am Morgen aber auch mehr
Tod mehr Zerstörung den Süden des
Gazastreifen traf diesmal die
militärische Kraft Israels sie traf den
Mann der hier für den Islamischen Jihad
das Kommando hatte Befehlshaber radet
man Suhr gezielt getötet bei den
Angriffen in Rafa werden auch Zivilisten
verletzt die Palästinenser melden nicht
nur zahlreiche Notaufnahmen sondern auch
fünf Tote darunter ein Kind
sie haben diese Gegend ohne irgendeine
Vorwarnung angegriffen sie liegt neben
einem Krankenhaus es ist ein überfülltes
Viertel Kinder Frauen und alte wohnen
hier
Trauer und Wut auch im Norden des
Gazastreifen in jabalia sterben fünf
Kinder und ein Erwachsener für diese
Toten macht Israel eine fehlgeleitete
Rakete des Islamischen Jihad
verantwortlich
keine israelische Aktion in dieser
Gegend zu dieser Zeit der islamische
Jihad tötet Kinder in Gaza
zum Beweis veröffentlicht Israel dieses
Video das den Absturz der
palästinensischen Rakete zeigen soll
Bilder sind Waffen für beide Seiten und
Kameras sind überall nachdem hinter den
Kulissen Ägypten vermittelt hat soll
seit wenigen Minuten seit 19 Uhr
deutscher Zeit eine Waffenruhe gelten
israel hat zugestimmt es hat seine
militärischen Ziele erreicht die Antwort
des Islamischen Jihad werden die
nächsten Stunden geben
aus Gaza wurden in den vergangenen drei
Tagen mehr als 500 Raketen abgefeuert
die meisten konnte Israel abfangen
mit den getreideexporten aus der Ukraine
geht es voran vier weitere Schiffe haben
am Morgen ukrainische Häfen verlassen
beladen mit etwa 170.000 Tonnen Getreide
und Sonnenblumenöl sind sie unterwegs in
Richtung China Türkei und Italien wegen
der russischen Angriffe waren in den
vergangenen Monaten alle Getreideexporte
der Ukraine aus ihren schwarzmeerhäfen
blockiert worden
Verfassungsschutzpräsident Haldenwang
sieht die Extremisten in der AFD nach
ihrem letzten Parteitag gestärkt das
sagte er gegenüber dem ZDF dem
widerspricht Parteichefin Weidel im ZDF
sommerinterview und stellt die
Unabhängigkeit des Verfassungsschutzes
in Frage befragt zum ukraine-krieg
verurteilt sie den russischen Einmarsch
zwar als völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg spricht aber auch von
Fehlern des Westens David Geppert
wenige Wochen ist Alice Weidel
Parteivorsitzende der AFD einer Partei
aus der heraus immer wieder auf
Verständnis geäußert worden war für den
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine Weidel
verurteilt diesen zwar und sieht doch
eine Mitverantwortung beim Westen die
Russen haben immer ganz klar und
deutlich gemacht dass sie keine
gegnerische macht in ihrem Hinterhof
akzeptieren würden und die Ukraine nicht
gleich auf eine neutralen Status Gesetz
zu haben das ist der Fehler den der
Westen sich angreifen lassen muss seit
März dieses Jahres wird die AFD als
Verdachtsfall für Rechtsextreme
Bestrebungen vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet auch ein Gericht sah
ausreichende tatsächliche Anhaltspunkte
für verfassungsfeindliche Bestrebungen
im Juni dann Wahl eines neuen
afd-vorstands erstmals seit der
Neuaufstellung der Partei äußert sich
der Verfassungsschutz Chef und warnt im
ZDF nach dem Bundesparteitag der AFD in
Riesa sehen wir eine Stärkung der
extremistischen strö in der Partei im
neuen Bundesvorstand findet sich kein
dezidierter Kritiker des formal
aufgelösten rechtsextremistischen
verdachtsfalls Flügel mehr Weidel
widerspricht greift die Behörde an
unabhängig
den es sonst nirgendwo gibt der
Verfassungsschutz fehlt jetzt politisch
instrumentalisiert um eine
Oppositionspartei noch und Löcher zu
verunglimpfen und darum weißes Gericht
darauf muss man auch Hinweisen man hat
schon gesagt der Verfassungsschutz hat
ausreichende tatsächliche Anhaltspunkte
die AFD eine neue Vorsitzende und alte
Probleme die Haltung zu Russland und die
Frage wie umgehen mit dem rechtsextremen
Flügel
das ganze Alice Weidel Interview gleich
im Anschluss an uns oder jederzeit in
der ZDF heute App
für die Finanzierung eines
Nachfolgemodells des neuen euro-tickets
stünden keinerlei Mittel zur Verfügung
und das hat Finanzminister Lindner in
der Augsburger Allgemeine nochmals
klargestellt eine Gratismentalität aller
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen auch im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr überzeuge ihn
nicht das Ticket sei zudem nicht fair
denn Menschen auf dem Land die auf das
Auto angewiesen sind würden den
günstigen Nahverkehr subventionieren
zum Berliner Grunewald da bleibt die
Arbeit der Einsatzkräfte schwer und
gefährlich es gebe immer noch mehrere
Brandnester so die Feuerwehr die
versucht den Gefahrenbereich weiter zu
verkleinern und sich weiter in die
Sperrzone vorzukämpfen Christoph destill
berichtet
über 100.000 Euro kostet ein
löschroboter ist aber unbezahlbar da wo
es für die Helfer zu riskant wird 500
Meter rund um den Sprengplatz dort
könnten alte Granaten Bomben und
Munition immer noch lebensgefährlich
werden
zwar sind die meisten Brandherde vom
Donnerstag gelöscht der Boden ist aber
weiter extrem heiß zwei Roboter gibt es
um ihn mit Löschwasser zu kühlen
dahinter tasten sich die Feuerwehrleute
langsam voran wie weit das entscheiden
Sie nicht allein
dazu wird den wenn dann auch ein
Sprengmeister zur Seite gestellt der
dann vor Ort direkt die Lage immer
wieder beurteilt wenn unsere
Einsatzkräfte auf Gegenstände stoßen im
Waldgebiet die sie nicht einordnen
können ob von denen eine Gefahr ausgeht
oder nicht
aktuelle Einschätzung zur Lage auf der
AVUS der Autobahn nah beim Sprengplatz
ist es noch zu gefährlich bis mindestens
morgen Vormittag bleibt sie gesperrt
aber die Gleisstrecke direkt dahinter
ist freigegeben Berlin Potsdam im Zug
das geht inzwischen wieder
doch warum Brand und Explosion kaum zu
sagen solange die Ermittler nicht in die
Sperrzone reinkommen andere kommen dort
vorerst nicht raus eine Herde Schafe
lebt fast direkt am Sprengplatz so
normalerweise das Gras daneben kurz
halten die Tiere sind auf ihre Tränken
angewiesen die müssen eben kontrolliert
werden dass da noch Wasser drin ist
nicht dass uns die Tiere verdursten weil
der Schäfer kann nicht ran der darf
nicht ran auch dazu also kann ein
Wasserwerfer gut sein um gezielt aus
sicherer Entfernung leere scharfs
trinken aufzufüllen
nach den Überschwemmungen im
kalifornischen Nationalpark dead Valley
haben Rettungskräfte hunderte Menschen
in Sicherheit gebracht am Freitag kam es
dort zu heftigen Sturzfluten
zwischenzeitlich waren laut
Parkverwaltung alle Zugangsstraßen
blockiert dutzende Autos steckten in den
Schlammmassen fest dass Depp Valley gilt
eigentlich als eine der trockensten und
heißesten Orte der USA
und jetzt sind wir beim Sport und
Kristin und WM Gold gleich zweimal sogar
nach fünf Medaillen gestern ohne Gold
gab es am zweiten Tag der Kanu
Weltmeisterschaften in Halifax Kanada
einmal Bronze zweimal Silber und auch
zwei WM Titel für die deutsche Flotte im
Kanadier zweier setzten sich über 1000
Meter dank eines tollen schlussspurs
Sebastian Brendel und Tim Hecke durch
vor den Duos aus China und Kanada nach
Platz vier gestern über die halbe
Distanz für die deutschen ein
persönlicher wm-abschluss und für
Sebastian Brendel das insgesamt elfte WM
Gold überraschend und erfreulich auch
der Triumph von Martin Hiller und Tamas
Grossmann im Kajak zweier über 1000
Meter vor Italien und Ungarn
zum Fußball im ersten Sonntagsspiel des
bundesligaauftakts kam RB Leipzig beim
VfB Stuttgart nicht über ein 1:1 hinaus
beim Pokalsieger soll die Rückkehr von
Torjäger Timo Werner vom FC Chelsea
unmittelbar bevorstehen berichten
verschiedene Medien und borussia
Dortmund hat sich mündlich mit dem
ersten fC Köln über den Wechsel von
Anthony modeste geeinigt
jetzt seinen Fanliebling und top Stürmer
die Bestätigung folgte am Nachmittag von
FC Geschäftsführer Christian Keller wir
haben auf Wunsch von Tony modest hin
heute Mittag mit dem BVB mündlich eine
grundsätzliche Einigung über seinen
Wechsel zum BVB erzielt Dortmunds
Sportdirektor Sebastian Kehl äußerte
sich nahezu wortgleich der mit 20
Treffern viertbeste Torschütze der
vergangenen Bundesliga-Saison soll bei
Schwarz-Gelb den Ausfall von Sebastian
Alea kompensieren laut übereinstimmenden
Medienberichten außerdem so gut wie
sicher die Rückkehr von Timo Werner vom
FC Chelsea nach Leipzig eine
Überraschung denn erst kürzlich sagte RB
Trainer Domenico tedesco er sei mit dem
aktuellen Kader zufrieden
ja der Wechsel ein guter Zeitpunkt
wahrscheinlich im WM Jahr
Nationalmannschaft mit Endspiel am 4
Tage Kristin es bleibt relativ
sommerlich und Bäume durstig wir schauen
auf die Aussichten morgen im Norden
zeitweise Dichter bewölkt sonst meist
ruhiges Wetter weiterhin zu trocken mit
hoher Waldbrandgefahr die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 21 und 32
Grad
um 21 Uhr empfehlen wir das heute
journal mit Christian Sievers von uns
danke fürs zuschauen für Sie einen
schönen